this is your eighth film you've said
that you might retire after your tenth
is that you are you serious about that I
think I am actually I mean you know and
like I could extend it to 11 or
something but I don't think it's gonna
be 14 or 15 or anything like that I
think it's about I think 10 sounds good
well what I'd like about that I'd 1 I
just I kind of I want there to be an
umbilical cord from my first film to my
last film as opposed to and I'm not
making fun of anybody else who feels
differently and a lot of directors work
for a long time but I don't want to just
be a director who just works for a long
time and like creatively maybe it's like
not going as up as it was before it's
going down the hill a little bit more
and then also just because a lot of
directors just keep directing because
they don't know what else to do I mean
it's their life and they that's all they
know what to do and I like the idea of
doing a body of work 10 movies and then
okay that's it that's what I have to say
and let that filmography just stand for
itself
would you just would you write then oh
yeah yeah oh no no I would like no I'm
I'm a writer and as my work has been
taking a turn towards the literary
anyway I think in the last 10 years so I
would write plays and probably direct
them I could write novels I'd write film
pieces and film criticism books and you
know things like that I'll be a man of
letters barren land of letters that
actually sounds like another nice way to
spend your twilight years no one says
that man of letters anymore I like that
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography